>>She said baseball and soccer.
>>Diana: Every kid has an interest.
Sometimes he doesn't know what it
is, sometimes he can't articulate it.
But every kid has an interest,
that's a fundamental belief.
If you can't buy into that, then you
can't buy into the work that we do.
>>In this day and age, the
responsibility of libraries, museums,
schools, after-school programs, the
type of institutions we work with,
is to not only help that
kid identify the interest,
but progress through that
interest, become more advanced.
It's just the same
job as a tennis coach,
the same job as a football coach.
It's the academic coach.
>>So I'm Diana Rhoten, I'm
an organizational sociologist.
I work at the Social
Science Research Council.
One of my projects right now
is called the New Youth City
Learning Network.
It's in New York City;
it's a consortium
of about a dozen institutions.
We're working together to create new,
digitally-enabled learning activities
and create new youth
networks across the city.
>>The notion of interest-driven
learning is not a new concept.
In fact, it's quite
an old conversation,
but it's a conversation that's been
enlivened recently by two things:
unprecedented technical
infrastructure
and new empirical evidence
around learning.
What we see in the kids
that we're working with is,
they want an experience that means
something to them personally.
They want to be able to
relate it into the context
of their own lives or
their own interests.
Then they wanna be able to reshape
that story and tell it in the context
of their own lives and interests.
And then they want to
be able to translate
that into something they can do
in the community, they can do--
whether that's an online
community or a physical community.
So it's really a--
it's going consumption,
production, participation.
>>"What does this mean?"
I mean, we had to start there.
So part of the reframe was,
we're talking about
learning, not education.
What's that difference?
We're talking about digital media;
we're not talking about
big technology.
We're talking about learner centered,
rather than institutional driven.
So there's a lot of sort
of ground leveling to do,
in terms of just basic understanding
of what this transformation
might mean.
We're trying to get
them to think about,
what happens if you take your assets
around biodiversity, for example,
and start putting them out there in
a way that a kid can incorporate them
in a narrative that he or she
finds personally motivating,
personally relevant,
personally interesting?
And then ways in which they might
be able to do dynamic remodeling
around that asset, dynamic mapping
around that asset,
dynamic story telling.
Because, you know, part
of the opportunity here
is learning the content,
which is very much the twentieth
century idea around education.
But in twenty-first century, it's
learning the tools and the skills
of remaking that content and becoming
the creator and the producer.
>>We have a mandate
and we have a mission.
You know, we wanna go
through this process,
at the end of which we can
demonstrate what digital media
learning tools can do.
We started on the edges.
These are institutions
that are central to a city,
but not necessarily central
to a kid's life right now.
They're more flexible; schools are
highly structured around standards
and assessment right now,
so it's very difficult.
Even where there's a will, it's very
difficult for a teacher right now
in a formal school
setting to think about,
"How do I incorporate this
mobile-based geolocative game
into my classroom?"
Can't even use mobile phones in
New York City classrooms right now,
whereas if you come to a place
like the Natural History Museum,
or you go to the Wildlife
Conservation Society,
not only do they have the assets
to teach about that subject matter,
but they can use the tools
and they can practice
and demonstrate the tools.
We don't have enough positive
examples of what this means.
We have a lot of discourse around it,
but we don't have a lot of concrete,
positive examples of
how do you do this?
And that is our job right now; we
have to put that out in the world,
so that the chancellors
and the principals
and the teachers understand that
this isn't just about media arts
and crafts, but it's about using
the tools to get to the content
and the skills and the
competencies that they value.